so if we now move on to the next example
this one has to do with
power stations
for electric cars
Maybe some of your fans of Tesla.
but here is
the idea
Okay, we will look at this.
example problem to understand
the notation of the random variable the concept of the random variable
and the application of the random variable.
So let's let's look at this. Let's look at the story and see what it's about at the
airport. There are two recharge stations for electric cars.
Okay, so instead of a petrol station.
you have to
recharge stations for electric cars
at both recharge stations
There are four Chargers.
so instead of having pumps you have
you know like this huge.
Power supply with the cable that like a USB a
USB cable that goes into your car.
Each station has four of them at the airport.
Maybe have one for the arrival section one for the
departure section. We are going to see more of these by the way.
But now let's consider an experiment.
Where the number of numbers of chargers are
in use at both of the stations?
Okay, for example in one experiment.
We have 13 and 40. What does this mean?
Let's say you're looking at the camera.
You're looking through the camera to see how many cars are at the
station in one station.
one charger is being
consumed and three Chargers being consumed. Let's say
in the arrival Section 3 cars are using the Chargers.
the other station
for the departures
four charges and two Chargers are being used. That's what these numbers
mean.
Okay.
So here we have six charges that are actively being used.
six charges are
active at post station at the same time.
in the sample space
entirety of the outcome
There are 25 possible outcomes in
any given experiment.
So I said an experiment can be rolling a dice flipping a
coin but here it can be a day or
a particular hour.
Or cars are parked at the stations and they're charging
their their cars.
25 possible outcomes
from any given experiment and you're listening table
below.
And let's see and I'll tell you what, this is. So let's zoom in here for
a second.
So for example
It could be.
This is for station one and Station 2. It could be that at
station one.
Where you have the departures, there's one car and only one car
is charging their.
car
and if you look at the
Recharge station at the arrival section. There's no car.
That's why you have one and zero.
We have to count the zeros to in the sample space because it could be that it
could be that there are no cars in either station.
or for example
We look at this this cell in
the table.
right
where
three chargers at station two are being used and three chargers
at station one are being used.
now if we count all of these
outcomes
There will be 25.
25 including
zero and zero
where neither of the morphine used
Okay. Now, let's see what the what the problem is asking us
to do.
assume an experiment
s is performed.
Meaning this experiment takes place where you have
cars driving to the stations.
assume
that
an experiment is performed and outcome is
two three
So two charges at station one is a being
used in three charges at Station
2 is being used.
Okay, cool. That's that's our experiment.
now Define three random variables
where
so these are three random variables notice how they're all uppercase.
X
Contains the total number of charges in use at both stations.
Why the difference between the numbers of charges at
both in both stations Station 1 versus session two
and Z the maximum number of charges in active use
at the both state at both stations. Think about this think about
these problems for a few seconds. Think about the
first one start with the first one. How do you how would you go about solving
this problem?